Or you know, the black widow,
she mates with her male mate
and then she snuffs them.
So I'm working on
this estrogen thing heavy,
it's going to be part
of that Geiger counter thing.
I, okay, embarrassment, I'm
56 years old and I'm a virgin.
I'm sorry-
Technically, but has
the bell gone off yet?
The bell has not gone off
but testimony should be relevant
to the item before.
Officer Carr,
you remember when you voted?
And you can answer this
after I sit down.
Three minutes.
Your time is up.
There are some folks
in little Austin town,
don't have a lot of dough.
They're not using
all your gasoline,
they like to go real slow.
My legal name is Greg Gay.
I was bullied.
I had my head
shoved in the urinal.
Lance, you were the one that
shoved my head in the urinal.
Thank you.
Bitches ain't shit
but hoes and tricks.
Look on these nuts
and suck the dick.
That's Snoop Dogg.
I am not a sexually
active person. I do no sex.
There's a movie called
A-R-R-O-Y-O 2014.
Get up and watch it.
And guess what,
I'm not the rancher.
Not the rancher's wife,
not the rancher's kid,
not that I couldn't have been.
That's not the path
I chose, was it?
My ex-husband's the killer.
And news flash, he's not dead.
I have two boobs, not six.
I have six butts because when
you guys are talking about me,
you have no idea
who knows me.
Sane people know that showing up
at their local
city council meetings
will accomplish nothing.
That's why I asked you
to send me any complaints
about your community
and I will give them
the national platform
they don't deserve in a segment
I'm calling, local twissues.
First, in my town of Glen Cove,
my neighbors believe
that they own the street
so they put out cones
to reserve parking spots.
One neighbor in particular
doesn't like his cones touched
so he goes off
whenever someone moves his cone
or his recyling bin
he uses as a third cone.
Oh ho, I recommend
settling this with violence.
The Steak N Shake in
Cape Girardeau, Missouri,
closes at 10PM.
That's too early.
Please help us.
Tucker, I hear you,
but you really shouldn't
be eating steaks
or shakes after 10PM.
Now, if you have to,
buy a heat lamp.
Then pick up your food at 10
and keep it warm
until you're hungry.
My city, Clayton, Missouri,
banned golf carts
on the streets.
I've been driving my golf cart
on the streets for years.
The surrounding cities allow it,
but I have to drive illegally
to get out of Clayton.
Help me.
Okay, now here's what you do,
buddy.
Carry a golf ball
with you at all times,
then when you get pulled over,
you tell those do-nothing sons
of bitches running Clayton,
that you're playing
your ball where it lies.
There's no Wifi
in my high school
and they make us use our phones
for a bunch of things,
wasting data I can't afford.
Also, they opened up
a second cafeteria
in recent renovations called,
the internet café,
but they don't allow students
to connect to the wifi.
Better be careful
writing with all caps,
they're gonna
put you on a list.
I'm tired of these spandex
wearing cycle freaks
parading around
in their bicycle gangs,
slowing down traffic
in Gwinnett County, Georgia.
We need to introduce lions
to the local population
to cull this
Lance Armstrong herd.
I like where your head's at.
I fully endorse releasing lions
in the streets of Georgia.
I'm just surrounded by idiots.
Kalkaska, Michigan.
Well, sure you are,
you live in Kalkaska.
The principal at our high school
in Wisconsin
has slept with
multiple faculty members
and even had a pregnancy
scare with one of them.
And no, I'm not talking
about his wife,
who is also a faculty member
at the same high school.
All right you little snitch,
you mind your own
God damn business.
And let adults
do what adults do.
Tell Travel Magazine to stop
naming
Charleston the number one city
in the country.
It's driving
all the Ohioans here.
You'd have to live in Ohio
your entire life to believe
Charleston is the number
one city anywhere.
What is this, Beverly Hills?
No, this is Charleston,
South Carolina.
This looks just like Malibu.
No, Charleston.
Is this South Beach Miami?
No, no, it's Charleston.
Is this New York City?
Oh, look at all this energy.
No, it's Charleston,
South Carolina.
Hey, is this the windy city,
it was such great food.
No, no, you're in Charleston.
Charleston, South Carolina.
How many other ...
Austin, is this Austin?
So much culture,
so much good music.
No, no, this is Charleston,
South Carolina.
You can tell because
we still have
one of our old slave
auction blocks.
I don't think I'm far off.
Vandalia, Ohio.
There are no sidewalks connected
to the middle school for kids.
Well, it's probably
for the best,
we can stand to have
a few less middle schoolers.
Same sex couples can't go
to prom together.
Commerce, Oklahoma.
You guys got one of those
boring ass cis proms?
You should at least
be allowed to use the back door.
You get it?
Sherwin Williams has dumped
toxic waste
from their paint
in Gibbsboro, New Jersey,
and now it's causing a lot of
health issues for the residents.
It's classified
as a cancer cluster
and the residents
have mental health issues.
The land, water,
and air are toxic.
This sounds like it might be
more of a Netflix docu-series
kind of problem.
We need a damn Popeyes Chicken
in Stillwater, Oklahoma.
Do the Lord's work, Daniel,
bring me some of that finger
licking goodness.
Okay, first of all, finger
licking goodness is KFC,
you confused Okie.
I live in Maplewood, Minnesota,
and it's shaped like a bunch
of cities were glued together.
It sure is, I am all
for re-drawing all city lines
until everything looks
like a perfect square.
Hashtag squarey-mandering.
Our neighborhood has a
sewer problem in Orange, Texas.
It's the Nottingham neighborhood
off of highway 87.
The slightest rain
and nobody can flush.
Help us fix this please.
You sure it's not all those
husky brisket
dumps you guys
are famous for?
Warwick, Pennsylvania.
Our school district
still doesn't offer
full-day kindergarten
but somehow expects children
to walk into first grade
being able to read.
It forces working parents to
have to pay for private daycare.
Most of other
surrounding districts
already offer
full day kindergarten.
Okay, let me tell you something.
How dare they make you
spend more time
with your shitty,
illiterate children.
Who needs kindergarten
in Pennsylvania, anyway.
You're just gonna end up
working in a coal mine.
Kalamazoo, Michigan.
Pair of shitty panties,
water bottle,
and a pack o Newports
on the corner of our busiest
road, been there for weeks.
You sure it's not a roadside
memorial for some light lizard.
Pay your respects just to be
safe, then pick it up.
Sometimes, my fish tacos
aren't hot enough.
Honolulu, Hawaii.
Well, mahalo for
your patience, Hawaii.
Go outside, hold it
over your lava for 30 seconds.
You'll have all the heat
you can handle.
Twitter has ruined America.